[Music]
and drugs for desire news submitted by
the Joe Malian animal animal sanctuary
Oh cute
that's Geo store oh yeah oh thanks oh
it's not a story it's a sanctuary yeah
yeah the new Female Viagra has sparked a
debate over drugs and female sexuality
whoo
what is female of lions that do what I
think it does is it what do you think it
gets your [ __ ] really hard you're gonna
fail I thought it was gonna get the
whole vagina just warm and throbbing
equivalent yeah shivering like an old
man in a [ __ ] cane dude yeah yeah I
can see an enemy in the ocean when the
wave comes you guys are stupid do you
know what the medication does no but I
wouldn't say some stupid [ __ ] like that
was what I said stupid very what do you
think it what is it what do you mean the
medication does it I think it's probably
like it probably increases the blood
pressure and it probably relaxes the
muscles I have no idea that sounds just
as I said but I would not say it makes
the [ __ ] hard I didn't say the clear
heart that's him yeah you know that's
that look in his mind Quivers know
what's how they're talking about what do
you think it mean it does I don't know
because I don't know how it's supposed
to work how it doesn't work and how to
fix this just a question what I hit was
a grin sir yeah so back off so the FDA
has approved this new drug it's a libido
drug so it's called
by Lisi piety it sounds like a game of
Thrones character targaryen yes and it's
actually an injection it's an injection
oh hell no I'm okay Sam ladies got to do
too much crazy [ __ ] to their body
already do you inject it like I think
you're gonna inject
I'm not chopped right you gotta grab the
Clinton you just [ __ ] it in check that a
little bit it's not like you're shooting
into your butt cheek or anything that
won't be better than in your [ __ ] oh yes
so this is an injection that's that
woman's self administer to their thigh
or abdomen at least 45 minutes before
sexual activity and so this is actually
the second libido drug that goes on the
market the first one is called a D and
that is a an oral medication that you
have to take daily so like a pill but
they're saying here that desire is a
complex issue that a lot of
professionals believe that you can't
solve with a drug so for women it's it's
not an easy fix like for men like four
minutes easy you just take viagra and
then it's the function of just getting
your day for women libido and desire
it's much more than that it actually
it's like a it's psychological it has to
do with if we're in a happy relationship
that we even want to have sex to be one
begin we'd like to feel safe yeah
exactly to feel safe or you know they
had a good day that day
no it's if you had a good day that day
you feel comfortable feel comfortable
but there are so this these drugs are
aimed for women who actually suffer from
a disorder it's called hypoactive sexual
desire disorder which means you have
very low sexual desire and it's called
nun disease
it's called HSDD and so can foma maniacs
do none of the horniest [ __ ] on the
planet are they are the best nuns these
ladies they would make the best I'm not
getting elected to any public office
anytime soon to heaven they seem real
good though they do Sister Act was the
[ __ ] so they are saying here that having
HSDD
it results in distress or interpersonal
issues and usually it happens in
premenopausal women
so but you remember how I mentioned that
there was a drug already out called a D
it was approved in 2015 but has been
failing in both sales and results
they're saying that my lessee is not
gonna do anything like any better than
that people want to be horny that well
by Lisi sounds better than a D at all
yeah yeah grand problem there that's
true they just change the name yeah how
about wet and horny that would have been
to everyone
keep it straight pharmaceutical name wet
and horny yeah went wild wet and Wow yes
makeup brand well I'll be like give me
something that makes me wet and horny
but none of the medications are
straightforward like viagra she's just
because dick hard yeah yeah hard ass a
hard dick yeah hard ass dick
I think that'll sell like crazy well
viagra already sells but ya need the
branding
I like cialis I was forgetting what I do
the Fielder my girl you don't need a
name for dick heart pills like if a guy
finds it they'll be like yeah I'll take
that [ __ ] you call it like a rat poison
they're like yeah
mercury [ __ ] have you ever taken
viagra
no I'm scared I kind of want to but I'm
scared yeah cuz I heard that if you are
if you don't have that dysfunction and
you take it it can actually give you
that or the people wear it like stays
hard for like days yeah you have to go
to the ER yeah yeah and not everyone
reacts the same to the medicine that's
like a show I watched where this [ __ ]
couldn't stop coming and she has a
disorder oh my god I saw that yeah she
was like a fifty or forty year old woman
or he's doing the most she was just like
interview - oh yeah yeah it was awesome
she always did like jazz hands what
happened - that's crazy yeah I mean I
don't know from what like reading this
article here and there saying how four
women desire sexual desire can be a very
mental thing I feel like that's the same
for guys as well like when they
experience certain like
the problems a lot of the time is just
psychological and like I don't think
Mike yeah when I'm extremely stressed
out I'm not even horny and my dick don't
get hard and I was like I had that with
his one point when I was 23 I was going
through a bad time and I was like
thinking oh [ __ ]
it's happening I'm getting old 20 23
yeah but it was because I was working
graveyard shifts I never saw the Sun I
was very unhealthy I was I was I was
yeah I was sick for two months straight
so like I was I was just physically sick
and stressed out because I was just
working like non-stop so that's probably
what drove me there but when I became
happy and healthy again like I was like
I'm ready to [ __ ] um but I'm just a
little bit confused with this article um
maybe I missed something but I thought
the point was that it's supposed to hit
two different markets the first one is
for the hyper with a hypo hypo yeah and
then the second one was for pre
menopausal women no that's the same
thing so the high oh it's the same thing
yeah HSDD is usually happens in
premenopausal women yeah so because
estrogen levels are dropping know what
that means yeah but then then but then
the articles saying oh but the women
need to have that desire and that
whatever but it sounds like when you're
gonna hit menopause it's not a desire
thing anymore it's a biological thing
for sure so I guess what they're saying
here it's like yeah this is mainly for
these women that actually have a
disorder but like for Viagra for example
like men who can easily cure their Edie
by going to therapy or something
actually putting in the work they just
take this pill and they can get hard and
they can have sex but so they're saying
like they they just don't feel like this
should be used the same way for women
where like if you're experiencing a low
libido and you got a look into your
relationship we're looking to the stress
in your life and look into your health
and like other things that a drug
shouldn't have to be the solution for it
they're treating it like they're
treating it in the same angle the way
viagra was created yeah viagra screed
for I guess if there was a menopause in
in men where you're older that they have
a hard time getting it up so that's what
it's for but also the younger guys will
have EB or whatever you take it or like
you that just want
yeah so I think they're approaching the
same way this is for premenopausal women
but also other women who have the hypo
whatever because of whatever issues
maybe you can also take you to yeah well
okay so the other thing here is that
they're also pointing out and like
they're highlighting the fact that
viagra it either helps a man get an
erection or it doesn't and it's like a
functional thing right for female libido
drugs there may be subtler results that
you can't clearly see in the clinical
clinical trial so they're they're having
a problem with the fact that this is
even on the market like sorry no oh
that's true cuz then guys would be like
hey I wanna [ __ ] but my dick doesn't
work but then girls it's like their
[ __ ] always works it's it's it doesn't
have to always not work you know it's
like you have to you have to get you
don't have to get hard to [ __ ] like girl
it's just it's just there girls are also
the business yeah so then it's more of a
psychological desire thing to actually
enjoy exactly and so what some women may
feel that because of society how it's
like well you should be turned on
because again your doors wide open all
the time and then so they might feel
pressured to they don't want to do which
then lead them to taking this drug when
like I said they need to look at other
factors in their lives
yeah they should try drinking maybe with
a chick many years ago and she would
never wanna like do foreplay or anything
like that she just wants to get I
thought and then like oh that and then
she's just like lay back and be like
what like
aren't you gonna [ __ ] me and I'm like it
doesn't work like this I have to be
somewhat connected to you yeah to make
this happen otherwise this is just a
transaction I don't I need a [ __ ] -
yes so so for me that was a mental thing
though cuz I'm like I don't feel like
you were connected and I don't feel
desire during that [ __ ] yeah and yeah it
definitely makes it hard to get hard
yeah that's true
yeah lick my balls or something with my
athletes my [ __ ] absolute [ __ ]
like it hurt it hurts that you just want
me to like stick it in and pump it
say you felt that way right and you
can't get hard but then because of those
feelings and because you feel like well
a guy should be able to get hard or
whatever the [ __ ] like societal like
pressures in your own head then you go
and you get viagra like don't you think
that's kind of like well that's [ __ ]
up you should address the psychological
things right I've heard that with age
though it does happen for some people
know for sure I'm talking specifically
for his situation where he couldn't get
hurt because there was no emotional I
think a lot of dudes they try to
self-diagnose [ __ ] and just take care of
it themselves were man and so it's like
I'm gonna just take care of this I'll go
to a [ __ ] doctor if I have to put it
back over my head walk through the
office and go get a prescription for
Viagra even if maybe it is something
else on a dress because they're just
gonna try a different [ __ ] to try to
make their dick work again it might they
might not be the best approach but a lot
of dudes distinct like that's it
and a lot of the time people people and
it's not just the specific dinner they
don't even know that there's a issue
going on in their head mm-hmm it's just
you're so in this [ __ ] yeah you're so in
the [ __ ] that you don't even connect the
two so it's dope that this conversations
even happening and maybe even they can't
separate like all the stress in the day
from like that time we're at night where
you want to be with your with your
person like they can't get away from
that [ __ ] yeah this is why they should
drink alcohol
[Music]
[Music]